[Music]
you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
oh
the Conqueror
Kang the Conqueror is the new iconic
villain in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places that
we'd never been
I don't pity Ant-Man against a major
villain felt perfect
audiences have seen a version of this
character in the series Loki
this is wild
in our film he's very different Tang is
an infinite number of different personas
an actor to be able to pull that off and
that is Jonathan Majors I can rewrite
existence and shatter timelines in this
film this is really a side of him if we
haven't seen this is his baddest self I
will take my revenge on those who
banished me and I will burn them out of
time
I think the film is owes me about how
time plays within our relationship
love friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus
tank this is it people gonna lose their
mind
yeah if you leave at man
[Music]
is